[Applause]
taking me to sleep basketball or
bare-knuckle boxing we do everything
i'm stanley sugarman i'm a scout for the
76ers
so you're 22 years old because you can't
be in the draft if you're over 22. yes
i'm 22 years old who's this it's my son
[Music]
how old is he he's 10 years old
okay
okay
yeah
this philly thing
there's room to grow there i want to
coach someday do you love being away
from home all the time
best chance to win in here is with you
out there what the hell am i still
chasing this for so you're just gonna
give up on your journey been in this
league for 30 years and it's like
i'm nothing
[Applause]
i'm gonna start
you come to philly your whole world's
gonna change overnight i gotta work my
mom and my daughter they mean everything
to me salary is nine hundred thousand
dollars
he will call in sick
in all the years i've been doing this
have i ever reacted this way he's raw we
train him get him in nba shape
what do you say it's not gonna happen
stan you just gotta get back out there
you know i haven't been home on my
daughter's birthday for nine years
running i'm not asking
the sixers don't know you stashed
being the guy who finds the guy matters
in this business won't inspire you for
this i just want to make sure i do
what's right for the kid he's got a
daughter to support you got a daughter
to support where you from spain sounds
weird
you think you can stop me welcome to
america
that wasn't him that wasn't even close
to him
i flew home tomorrow is that what you
want to do hey you love this game
i love this game i live this game
let's get to work
the draft is in six weeks if we're gonna
do this we gotta do it ourselves no
doubt about it that kid's got it
do you need a handout
you don't need nobody's help
we need a spark
this is all for you pal he's for us okay
it's for us
[Music]
you